thank you for joining us Donald Trump
has arrived in New York where he'll
appear in court on Tuesday he'll be the
first former U.S president to face
criminal charges Trump was taken by
motorcade from the airport to his
Manhattan Residence at Trump Tower where
he'll spend the night he's been charged
in connection with an alleged hush money
payment to adult film star Stormy
Daniels during the 2016 presidential
election campaign Trump says the case is
politically political persecution at the
highest level and has called honest
supporters to protest let's go live to
Al jazeera's Gable Elizondo who's in New
York outside Trump Tower so Gabe what's
the latest verse about tomorrow's
arraignment
well we're just getting some new
information and it's a little after 10
p.m here local time in New York and
local media organizations and National
media organizations have been
petitioning the judge in this case to
allow cameras inside the courtroom
Trump's lawyers put out a memo to the
judge earlier on Monday saying that they
were against this well just in the last
few minutes we have gotten word that the
judge has made a ruling on that and he
will allow five still photographers in
the courtroom while Donald Trump is
arraigned this is significant because it
will be the only way that the public
will be able to have any sort of uh
evidence and documentation if you will
of this historic court appearance by
Donald Trump the judge also saying that
cameras will be allowed inside the
hallway area this is significant as well
too because once Trump gets to the
district attorney's office and after
he's processed there he'll have to walk
down a hallway to get to the court so
the judge saying cameras can be allowed
in that hallway to get images of trump
walking to the courtroom so clearly this
is some new information and we now know
that we will be able to see some sort of
photographs of Donald Trump as he's
being arraigned there's also going to be
a lot more happening on Tuesday and what
is going to be a very historic
appearance by Donald Trump the first
president of the United States or former
president ever to face criminal charges
it was all eyes and cameras on Donald
Trump as he arrived in his hometown New
York City on Monday afternoon but for
the rest of the day the former president
spent it away from the public eye in his
former residence Trump Tower in Midtown
Manhattan Trump will surrender to
Authorities on Tuesday after being
indicted by a Manhattan grand jury on
charges stemming from an alleged hush
money payment of over a hundred thirty
thousand dollars to a former adult film
star law enforcement is on a heightened
state of alert
amid fears of a repeat of the January
6th scenes when his supporters stormed
Congress in Washington D.C while you're
in town be on your best behavior
as always we would not allow violence or
vandalism of any kind and if one is
caught participating in any act of
violence they will be arrested and held
accountable no matter who you are Trump
is expected to arrive at the Manhattan
District Attorney's office around 11 A.M
local time under heavy security escort
inside Trump will have his fingerprints
and photograph taken the process can
take a couple hours the former president
is not expected to be handcuffed and
it's unlikely he'll be paraded through a
public place in front of photographers
what's known as a perp walk around 2 pm
he will be walked down a hallway to a
courtroom and come face to face with
this man judge Juan Merchant who will
oversee the arraignment at the
arraignment is when the indictment will
likely be unsealed and Trump and the
rest of the world will hear the charges
against the former president for the
first time
Trump is expected to plead not guilty
after it's over Trump will immediately
fly back to his Mar-A-Lago estate in
Florida where he is expected to speak
about the day's events for the first
time
over the years Trump has been the target
of numerous lawsuits and criminal
investigations dating back decades well
before he was ever president of the
United States he always found a way to
attack his adversaries And Delay any
potential criminal prosecution and to
allege wrongdoing but this time is
different what Trump will face on
Tuesday is unlike anything he has ever
experienced before and it's something
America has never seen before
Gabriel ozondo Al Jazeera New York
now Gabe we heard in your report the
mayor of New York's warning to Trump's
supporters what are the security
Arrangements in the city for tomorrow's
arraignment
well first of all there's many agencies
involved all the way from the FBI to the
Secret Service to the New York Police
Department which reportedly will have
more than 35
000 officers on duty on Tuesday to help
to provide security they're talking
about a lot of intermittent road
closures and the area around the
courthouse which is about six kilometers
south of Trump Tower where I'm at right
now the area will be almost completely
sealed off from any sort of traffic
either vehicle traffic or foot traffic
as well this is an incredibly
unprecedented situation and the security
apparatus to try to get a former
president to a courthouse in the middle
of one of the busiest cities in the
world to turn himself in and then get
him out of there safely is clearly top
of mind and that is why so many security
preparations are taking place not to
mention the fact this incredible amount
of curiosity about this whether it be
hundreds of just onlookers that try to
arrive there perhaps protesters as well
not to mention hundreds of journalists
from around the world add it all up and
this is certainly going to be a security
headache for all of those involved Gabe
thank you very much for that update
Gabriel is under with the latest there
from New York